we got some historic news off the top
here 50 years ago today today burglars
broke into the democratic national
committee headquarters in the watergate
complex you know the name it was the
beginning of an unprecedented political
scandal that ultimately led to the
downfall of president richard nixon
there's the big goodbye
cbs is marking the historic anniversary
with a new documentary breaking down
exactly what happened including
reporting from cbs news's leslie stahl
as events unfolded here's a clip
watergate was not about the burglars
right watergate was about
a whole campaign
of sabotage and espionage about cover-up
about a war against the press a war
against the system of justice
it was a subversion of our democracy
people have got to know whether or not
their president is a crook
well i'm not a crook he said he wasn't a
crook but that was the point
he was a crook the central mysteries
still remain
what were those men after at the
watergate who sent them how were they
paid
what's making the republicans nervous is
it's beginning to look as though some
members of the president's reelection
committee may know the answers
as the january 6 hearings continue in
washington the watergate story continues
to echo today offering potential lessons
about the current political landscape
leslie stahl who you just saw there a
moment ago in that clip was a rookie
reporter at the time and covered the
scandal from the very first day there's
another shot of her and leslie joins us
now leslie good morning gee
that's you look at myself
years ago you look great then you look
great down there it is there you are uh
watergate was a very slow boil we're in
72 50 years ago nixon doesn't resign
till 74. so what were those early days
like well first of all
that the anniversary of the break-in
which is today would come right in the
midst of these hearings now
and there really is a resonance
uh in the early days
almost nobody believed that this was
going to amount this break-in was going
to amount to anything and you said i was
a rookie that's why they sent the rookie
it wasn't a story
there were very very very few news
organizations covering it at all
what was the moment that made it not
just the story of the rookies on but a
story the whole nation is paying
attention to well at five hearings it
finally went into the senate and they
staged these
incredibly long
stunning hearings
where there was a narrative because they
started with the lower level people and
built and built and as the hearings
progressed
you realize the whole thing was pointing
first to the white house then to the
oval office
and you kind of get that same sense now
that as these things as these hearings
progress yeah you know the the arrow
is pointing and moving and it there is
that kind of similarity i do wonder
though back then 80
of americans watched at least some of
the hearings sunday morning reported on
sunday that 30 to 40 hours was what the
average american household consumed in
terms of those hearings they were long
and people were watching but there was
nothing else to watch we had three
networks all three covered them live
if you turned on television or radio
you had it in your face yeah
public opinion
really nevertheless
changed because much because of those
hearings
you know in the you note in the
documentary that richard nixon was a man
of contradictions
and many people believe the same thing
why do you believe it's important
to remember that
because
presidents almost are never one thing
and you want to understand the support
that a president in a crisis like we're
going through when we went through then
where the
the
honesty
in the white house is questioned
you want to understand why the other
side
is supporting him um and because in both
cases
these presidents did things
um that a great majority of the country
liked
you know nixon he was not a down the
line conservative right he was an
environmentalist he had a really good
civil rights record he started
affirmative action and he started
affirmative action and that's one reason
a lot of women and minorities came into
the workforce there was a duality yeah
in him yes as a man and when you when
you when you look at them most americans
do believe there's this divide right i'm
curious back then was there we're coming
out of the civil rights movement
here we are we're coming out of a
different kind of movement a backlash
what's your take on this divide and how
this hearing
in in these proceedings might move us in
a direction one way or the other well i
brought up the idea that public opinion
wasn't swayed that much from the
hearings even though 80 of the country
was watching them
these
if if you have
someone who voted for a president
they they are going to be committed
until you bang them on the head
and
watergate was a bang on the head when we
finally heard the president's voice
basically saying i've been lying to you
and i did get involved in the cover-up
it was illegal
um if not for those tapes i am totally
convinced nixon would have
carried through to the end of his term
and well the other key thing in this
roger mutter i remember the the clip he
comes out reports on cbs the republican
party this is a near direct quote the
republican party has given up on richard
nixon wow hard to imagine today yeah i
mean this is all out in the open too
well you know people forget that the
republicans stood by nixon almost to the
very end
it collapsed because of public opinion
the polls just went just
he was down in the 20s right
if he hadn't gotten that
low the
congress would have supported him and he
would not have resigned yeah
50 years on we got to leave it here
thank you very much for joining us you
can see the full documentary watergate
high crimes in the white house tonight
9pm eastern right here on cbs